trans athletes and allies are fighting a
surge of proposed anti-transgender
legislation
across the u.s many of these bills have
aimed to ban
trans athletes from competing on teams
that affirm their gender identities
trans girls and trans women are the main
targets of these bills with backers
believing they have an unfair advantage
over
cisgender competitors but trans rights
advocates say
it's not about wins and losses lindsay
hecox's dream of running cross-country
for boise state
was put on hold when idaho passed house
bill 500
in the spring of 2020. billie jean king
candace parker
megan repino and almost 200 other
athletes signed an
amicus brief speaking out against the
law which has since been suspended
this isn't the first time the sports
world has pushed back against anti-trans
legislation
in 2016 the nba and ncaa
pulled major events out of north
carolina in response to a bill
prohibiting trans people from using
public restrooms that match their
identity this contributed to the law's
partial repeal
in 2017. but athletes like cece telfer
the first out trans woman to win an ncaa
title
want to see the organization take a
firmer stance on current legislation
as a trans athlete uh first of all i'm
not a trump i'm not a threat to the prom
woman's sport
because i am a woman the ncaa has since
stated host sites must be
free of discrimination trans students
will also now be protected under title
ix the surge of legislation is
unprecedented
but discrimination against trans
non-binary and intersex
people is not new pride month
historically celebrates and honors
lgbtq plus communities but activism
against anti-trans legislation reminds
us of where pride began
in struggle and for visibility power
solidarity and equality